ce week end vous avez peut être croisé dumbo,
tintin et milou ou winnie l'ourson... rien de
plus normal. Ces proues de radeaux attendent
le défilé de Jour de Cher : des embarcations
mises au point depuis plusieurs semaines,
aujourd'hui prêtes pour la fête et parmi les
bateaux celui des super héros : "9...
9 à 10 week-ends de construction donc
tout du papier mâché, soit Hulk de 2,50 m."
"C'est notre journée, les enfants ils sont
gardés par les papys et mamies, et là c'est
vraiment notre journée à nous, les adultes".
Un peu plus loin des habitués de
Jour de Cher : quatre amis qui
ont choisi cette année l'ouest des états-unis.
"Une bande de copains de civray de touraine voilà,
tous voisins, tous copains, et là on
s'éclate au bord du Cher, sur le cher,
(Tous blonds?) "tous blonds ! Presque..."
Au fil de l'eau des écluses et des guinguettes le
cher rassemble. Une itinérance festive entre Bléré
et Saint-Georges qui met en lumière le patrimoine
exceptionnel avec lequel les habitants de la
vallée entretiennent une relation particulière.
"Y'a deux jours, j'allais faire du canoë sur le
cher... ça fait un peu... Bon c'est pas la plage,
c'est pas la mer, mais voilà on va sur le
bord du Cher, on va sur l'eau ça fait plaisir,
quand il fait beau comme ça c'est super
agréable, l'eau elle est super bonne."
"Aussi pour faire du sport, et pour
aller courir, pour se promener,
boire un coup à la guinguette à côté là..."
"Le cher à vélo c'est magnifique,
les gens sont heureux c'est très très bien
ce cher et c'est un bonheur de l'avoir".
"Parfois la pêche, pour sortir les enfants un peu
de canoë de temps un temps et puis les balades
surtout, c'est vraiment un endroit nature sympa,
on en profite au maximum, on a la chance d'habiter
ici donc c'est vrai que c'est chouette".
Un festival sur l'eau et à terre avec ses
concerts pour lequel les visiteurs
ont voté pour le plus beau radeau.